what promises to be another busy week of
confrontation and controversy at the
White House began today with new
presidential attacks on the Russia
collusion probe and more damage control
from presidential lawyer and recent
legal spokesman Rudy Giuliani
correspondent Kevin cork starts us off
tonight with a bevy of topics from the
North Lawn good even Kevin evening my
friend plenty to talk about now on a day
that saw the first lady unveil her
b-best platform the president frankly
Brett tried to take a back seat even
though he had sit in the front row at
the Rose Garden still it was an early
morning tweet storm by the
commander-in-chief that once again
managed to steal today's spotlight let
us teach our children the difference
between right and wrong and encourage
them to be best in their individual
paths in life a rarity at the White
House today as first lady Melania Trump
not her husband took center stage
rolling out her be best anti-bullying
campaign an effort which drew words of
encouragement from the president's
Polonia your care and compassion for our
nation's children and I have to say this
and I say to you all the time
inspires us all while the president took
second billing in the Rose Garden
an early morning tweet storm kept his
opinion about the ongoing Russia probe
front and center again calling it a
witch-hunt writing about 13 so-called
angry Democrats adding just wait till
the courts get to see your unrevealed
conflicts of interest that likely a
reference to the fact that more than a
dozen members of the Muller team have
donated almost exclusively to Democratic
candidates including to the Hillary
Clinton campaign and that according to
Federal Election Commission records it
kind of gives the American people a
glimpse of what we have to deal with day
in and day out with the abuses not so
much of Bob Muller but of the people
that work for him I mean they're way
over the top just how the White House
proceeds with the probe including
questions about whether or not the
president would comply with a potential
subpoena from Bob Muller is one that
outside counsel like Giuliani would have
to consider but over the weekend the
former New York City Mayor was
absolutely defiant in his assessment of
the president's right to do so
or not what happens if Robert Muller
subpoenas the president will you comply
well we don't have to he's the president
United States we can assert the same
privilege as other presidents have while
legal experts can debate the merits of
the mayor's argument what remains clear
is his roll out as a trump team
surrogate handling the numerous legal
entanglements has been less than smooth
something even Giuliani seemed to
acknowledge when again trying to explain
his previous comments about whether or
not the president knew Michael Cohen
paid stormy Daniels in the run-up to the
2016 election the facts I I'm still
learning this is you know 1.2 million
documents I've been in the case for two
weeks virtually one day in comparison to
other people so I I'm not an expert on
the facts yet I'm getting there Giuliani
by the way Brett repeated his claim that
the payment to daniels wasn't a campaign
expenditure it was not alone it was
simply a business expense I should also
point this out press secretary Sarah
Sanders today called him an added value
member of the president's outside legal
team one that continues to garner a
great deal of the spotlight Brett Warren
all that with the panel Kevin thank you